la tradición en Ucrania es que las
familias visitan los cementerios para
recordar a los suyos el primer domingo
después de la Pascua ortodoxa que en
esta ocasión se celebró exactamente hace
una semana ellos vienen a limpiar las
tumbas a traerles flores vienen con
comida pasan algunas horas con ellos
Incluso se les ve tomando algún vodka o
algún coñac para celebrar la memoria de
quienes han fallecido y esto incluye a
los militares especialmente en kiev no
hay un cementerio especial dedicado a
los militares para cada uno de estos
lugares y tiene sectores dedicados a
recordar la memoria de quienes han
fallecido defendiendo al país estamos en
uno de los cementerios más importantes
de la capital este lugar que está a mis
espaldas donde se ven esas banderas
ucranianas aquí están recogidos quienes
han fallecido defendiendo al país No
solamente Desde esa invasión a gran
escala ordenada por Vladimir Putin el
año pasado sino ya desde 2014 cuando
empezó Esa primera invasión liderada por
las tropas separatistas prorrusas en la
región del donbas miles de soldados y
ucranianos que han muerto defendiendo el
país muchos de ellos están enterrados en
este lugar y también es un día para
recordar a quienes han fallecido en
Ucrania especialmente en estos últimos
meses según la oficina de Derechos
Humanos de las Naciones Unidas
8.500 civiles han fallecido desde
entonces Pero ellos calculan que la
cifra podría ser muchísimo mayor y en
cuanto a militares el gobierno ucraniano
no da la cifra ni de heridos ni de
fallecidos Pero en esos papeles
estadounidenses filtrados días atrás el
gobierno de Washington Calcula que al
menos
350.000 soldados rusos ucranianos han
muerto quedado heridos desde entonces
ellos calculan que del lado ucraniano
entre 15.500 y 18.500 hombres habrían
fallecido del lado ruso sería muchísimos
más 35
500 a 43.000 según estos cálculos pero
el gobierno de kiev no lo confirma si
confirma que hay siete mil soldados
desaparecidos y se cree que al menos 60%
de ellos son prisioneros de guerra